[Applause]
four seasons in and the cast of stranger
things are definitely not strangers to
ridiculous onset antics so of course
we're taking a look at all the wholesome
content the cast gave us in season four
that's what it looks like underneath can
you believe that what a reveal that is a
reveal number one get your bets in now
the race is about to begin three two one
and they're off millie bobby brown
starts off with an early lead noah
schnapp seems to have developed a tummy
ache will he be able to recover in time
to beat millie no one can say for
certain but millie doesn't seem to be
slowing down in fact she's gaining speed
and her challenger is ducking out of the
race is this it for noah he's down and
out millie bobby brown is victorious
millie slayed at the fruit by the foot
challenge against noah schnapp who
gagged tough luck noah we wish you
better luck in the fruit roll-up
challenge number two did you hear millie
and noah made a pact to marry at 40 if
they aren't married already but they
would basically need to have separate
houses because hate to break it to you
they're just friends that doesn't stop
us from shipping them though maybe it
isn't too late for their characters
sorry finn the roller skating fail
between millie and noah is just clumsy
cute absolute ridiculousness on wheels
i just grabbed his boots whoopsie daisy
number three finn took an arrow just not
to the knee
whoa
if that's a metaphor for marriage what
does it mean to take one to the head
we could watch this all day i didn't
realize it would be so big these are
honestly the kinds of stranger things
moments that we live for sorry could we
go back this is so ridiculous
yes let's watch this part again
number four exterior shot sunrise
extreme close-up on quesadilla picture
this it's 5 30 in the morning after a
long night shoot you've fallen asleep in
your chair posied up beneath a thin
blanket for a 20-minute nap there's a
little bit of light in the horizon and i
open my eyes and caleb and gayton are
just sitting across from me staring
ahead eating a full-size like a
quesadilla sadie sink just finds the
idea of gayton and caleb going to town
on a quesadilla at 5 30 in the morning
absolutely hilarious for no good reason
why not cereal or eggs no no 5 30 is
quesadilla time
number five that feel when your favorite
moment on set is also your least
favorite finn's favorite moment had to
do with one long shot filled with
complex choreography including swooping
ducking and sneaking we only had like
three chances at it the characters were
ambushed and all of the choreography was
complex as they attempted to escape the
house unscathed we gotta go we gotta go
right now the actors were utterly
exhausted by the end of this one shot
they went through all the hard stuff
play it had all gone perfectly at least
up until the very last guy a soldier
supposed to come in and get shot and
then like shoot his gun up in the air
and that's it end of sequence and then
the camera whips to the door and the
soldier is not there so the director
calls cut and everybody's miserable
no no it's coming everybody's collapsed
to the ground heavy breathing and then
suddenly boom a door gets kicked in
and the stunt guy is like
and it shoots his gun up in the air so
he goes through his whole thing and then
collapses to the ground but the worst
part and then he got up and he was like
i think that went well
number six smile you're on camera we
need to find out an outfit that i get
arrested in
i've never thought i'd ever have to say
that simply
there are a lot of things you never
anticipate saying in life but when you
take a job in the arts anything is
possible like blowing things up with
your mind
number seven we know you look completely
ridiculous out there but you've got to
keep it together millie perhaps millie
couldn't help from laughing because
she's hyper aware of the fact she looks
11 years old and bald and is dressed in
a hospital gown in the middle of a
parking lot reasons for why one would
find themselves in this situation maybe
she just signed herself out of the
hospital for a little day trip to the
local target because she can't stand the
taste of hospital food and needs some
waffles hey it's one theory not a good
one but it's a theory bro i hate eggos
number eight what do you call the ball
with feathers on the end sorry actors
don't know much about sports usually
sports are dangerous look at poor
charlie he's proof
and sports are even more dangerous if
you're an actor pretending to be good at
them that's going to be a long recovery
process there's a reason the drama geeks
and the athletes don't get along take it
from stranger things number nine it's
like video games but in real life
okay it's more like playing video games
with your annoying brother who likes to
make every sound effect himself boom
boom sound effects just aren't half as
effective as the real thing we must say
number 10 all work and no play makes the
cast dull dull children this is why we
had to share with you all the instances
of them dancing with questionable levels
of enthusiasm why do all the actors like
to film themselves dancing like fools
what was their motivation
number 11. they may be dancing fools but
gayten is the worm king just look at him
go the worm king could almost be season
five's villain hear that duffer brothers
pull a wanda vision and make it gayton
all along number 12. actors only need a
passable knowledge of most things when
you're a child actor you hardly need
that either you could say actors are the
biggest example of jack of all trades
master of practically nothing that feel
when your stunt double is way better at
roller skating than you sometimes life
just isn't fair but we bet noah schnapp
is making way more money for doing way
less of the dangerous stunts so the
joke's actually on talented people
number 13. you know what's worse than
socks with sandals socks with bowling
balls and the secret is only good if you
don't drop the ball then you're in
serious trouble he was probably just
trying to save a couple bucks on rental
shoes and who can blame him for trying
to snag a good deal perhaps he could
become a trendsetter number 14. yes this
season of stranger things seems to
include a lot of sport which means a lot
of dangerous sportsball activities like
having to learn to drive golf balls
charlie heaton and eduardo franco got
really good at it but ridiculously their
training did not come in handy well it
did but it didn't jonathan and argyle
were totally out of their minds during
that scene so it isn't like the golfing
needed to be good per se what was i
supposed to do not lie not lie yeah not
lie so hey free golfing trip
number 15. listen closely charlie
heaton's unlocked the secret to acting
you got this man just me and you in here
that's what acting is
serious acting thank you charlie we will
never forget your wisdom what we want to
know is who his acting partner is that
needs such wise wisdom the cameraman or
is it us if so we're flattered
number 16. caleb's imagining things
remember like the semen we did like with
that one thing and it smelled weird what
are you talking about i know
it was pretty funky guess it was just
caleb smelling it you remember it was
like no i don't remember what smelled
man and you know what they say whoever
smelt it dealt it however he who denied
it supplied it so gayten we're looking
at you
number 17. sometimes it's the little
things sometimes it's the micro things
there's the popsicle situation where
everyone found themselves way too
fascinated with a trail of ants it was
kind of a rough day i remember but the
ice pops made it like
on one incredibly long and stressful day
on set the cast was treated to a
delicious icy treat but the ants also
wanted a taste so gayton had this bright
idea that they could lead them away with
a trail of popsicle juice this theory
never got to be tested because somebody
sprayed the ants but the actors seemed
to be so fascinated by this situation
that sadie sync even got a photo this
leaves us with one question why just why
between that and the quesadillas sadie
finds the oddest things interesting
number 18 time for a rewind back to the
best of season three millie bobby brown
and sadie sync really got to bond during
the filming of season three and
sometimes the wardrobe department does
their job and makes complementary colors
condiment each other ah meant to say
compliment each other my name's ketchup
and my name is mustard together with
ketchup and mustard
ketchup and mustard the musical
coming to a theater near you no time
soon
and
not such good condiments on popcorn
which is why this musical's a flop
number 19. the paper towel part of this
sport isn't dangerous it's what comes
next we're not really sure what we just
saw when you cheat at paper towel ball
prepare to get slapped we guess is that
a rule or foul play we don't know but
the idea of a sport that is both soft
and gentle and good at cleaning up
spills that's also an aggressive contact
sport sounds just so
intriguing
number 20 when kids see things that look
like slides they're inclined to use them
as such
we don't think you're supposed to slide
down that seriously there are signs and
everything but you know what it saves a
ton of time so we know what we're doing
next time mall security be darned
yes the cast is like two peas in a pod
two condiments on a burger they're doing
the sports ball all wrong but that's
okay they're making it uniquely their
own would you rather go bowling in your
socks or play a game of rock paper towel
slap that's what we're dubbing the game
let us know in the condiments uh
comments and thanks for putting up with
our complete lack of comprehension
surrounding sports at the things